[Applause]
and thanks to all of you watching here
thanks for coming welcome at home we
buckle up we got a 2-hour live show with
our studio uh audience tonight uh along
with a ton of breaking new developments
out of Israel Gaza by the way lot of
talk a lot of chatter tonight that the
ground Invasion into Gaza May begin as
early as this show in the next two hours
uh so we will keep you updated all
throughout the evening and also here at
home we had your President Joe just
wrapping up his second very rare prime
time address from the Oval Office Joe's
message to you the American people give
me more money including 14 billion for
Israel another 60 billion for Ukraine
take a look tomorrow I'm going to send
to Congress an urgent budget request to
fund America's national security needs
to support our critical Partners
including Israel and
Ukraine is a smart investment that's
going to pay dividends for American
Security for Generations help us keep
American troops out of Harm's Way help
us build a world that is safer more
peaceful more prosperous for our
children and
grandchildren now it didn't have to be
this way three years ago we had sound
policies our border was Secure we were
energy independent uh the world was
mostly peaceful uh we had a few uh Mean
Tweets that triggered many liberals in
the country but you know what there's
something that happened in the Trump
years and we'll get into more detail an
Alliance was created leading up to the
Abraham Accords where I didn't think I'd
see it in my lifetime with the United
States and Israel and Egypt and Jordan
and the Saudis and the Emirates they
were all United and sharing intelligence
and getting along better than they ever
have in our lifetime and it was all
against Iranian heemy that is now all
blown up because of the failure of Joe
Biden's foreign policy now we're on what
year two of a devastating war in Europe
uh a week week two of a brand new war in
the Middle East and after 32 Americans
were killed along with around
140000 other innocent men women and
children uh in what is the largest the
single most barbaric terrorist attack in
Israel's history by the way 11 Americans
are still unaccounted for likely taken
as hostages the IDF confirmed today 203
hostages are being held uh maybe more
this includes small babies are
propagandizing the Hamas terrorists
they're they're sending out videos on
the internet of these babies holding
them torturing the parents that are
desperately trying to get their kids
home then even young women and adults
they are being used as props as
propaganda props and according to one
senior Israeli official after weeks of
targeted air strikes the IDF has now
been given the green light to launch
their full-scale ground Invasion into
the Gaza Strip again that could happen
at any moment tonight and and today
Israel's defense Chief told his soldiers
to prepare for an imminent full-scale
assault phase two of the war against
Hamas it is now really imminent and just
before Joe announced what a100 million
in US tax dollars uh in terms of aid for
the Palestinian people are you you've
got to be kidding me does he really
believe the money will go to the
Palestinian people uh and let us not
forget their elected representatives are
the group Hamas the group Hamas has in
their Charter the destruction of Israel
as one of their top goals that money
will almost certainly end up in the
hands of Hamas I've seen this up close
in personal money from the US money from
Israel a network of underground tunnels
I have been in them they are
sophisticated the architecture
sophisticated cement and long Miles and
Miles 100 ft underground it's all over
going from Gaza to Israel it's insane
what they have done with the money that
was otherwise earmarked for hospitals
and infrastructure and schools no they
spent that money why to plan plot scheme
to kill more Israelis to take more
Israelis hostage the Administration has
no way to track that Aid once it crosses
the very border that Hamas controls in
other words Biden is likely gifting
terrorists a100 million in US taxpayer
assistance no how about if you're going
to give him any money at least get the
hostages back you know right get
something for it and if you want the
electricity and Gaza turn back on give
the hostages back you want the lights on
you want the water to flow you want
services to begin again give the
hostages back do that and and otherwise
you get nothing and it's not the first
time right after Biden was sworn in the
White House s what hundreds of millions
of dollars it ended up in the hands of
Hamas he's making the same mistake again
let's not forget about the tens of
billions of dollars that Iran is now
enjoying after Biden ease sanctions on
Iranian oil why would he want to make
the Iranians Rich again knowing that
they they desperately want and are
seeking nuclear capability of course the
money was used to orchestrate the terror
attack in Israel they were involved in
the plotting planning and scheming there
from Afghanistan to Iran to the border
to federal spending to making
decision making at this Administration
it has been horrendous every step of the
way and just last night the White House
tweeted this picture look at this you
know how do you make a mistake like this
it's Joe Biden meeting with our US
Special Forces here's the problem their
faces weren't pixeled out they were not
blurred out in the original post and
then hours after they end up doxing
members of our elite special forces and
putting them and their families lives at
risk oh the White House decided oh maybe
we should take that down saying oops so
sorry we regret the error and any issues
that it may have caused that's it that's
it really who made that mistake why are
they still working anyway there's no
accountability at the Biden White House
there's no leadership there and as we
have said many times the lights are on
at the White House but nobody's home we
saw that on Air Force One Last Night
according to reports Joe Biden sleeps a
lot he get he gets up late goes to bed
early tonight was a very late night for
him I bet he's exhausted if I had to
guess I bet he already had his warm
milky in a sippy cup and he's he's
already in Dreamland and he should be
watching the show I'm I'm offended by
that sorry I can't help it and lots of
time off in Delaware at a beach how do
you get to buy a beach house on a
senator's salary and have a beautiful
you know old Stingray Corvette worth
hundreds of thousands of dollars next to
Top Secret classified information uh
that Joe did not have his home rated for
or the upen rated for or his beach home
rated for or the University of Delaware
they only do that to Donald Trump anyway
when Joe is actually awake and he's at
the White House he has according to many
reports now fits of rage and struggles
to communicate well that was more than
obvious during his trip to Israel on top
of that remember world leaders said no
to meeting him the Egyptians didn't want
to meet him the dians didn't want to
meet him not even the Palestinian
Authority would meet with him and this
is him on Air Force One this is this is
Joe it is as ever his cognitive best
take a look can you talk about the
impact of meeting the survivors and
First
Responders that's all person look
I I spent an hour and a half about 17 or
18 before some them
and I don't know how to say
this virtually
every mass
shooting
every circumstance
where large number of people have been
victimized and lost I spoke with our
defense department says it's highly
unlikely that it was Israelis would have
a different footprint and have
intercepted some
anyway and uh so that's why if you
notice I didn't say at first I I wanted
to make sure that I knew and
look and I'm not suggesting that Hamas
deliberately did it either it's that old
thing got to Le how to shoot
straight uh you know and uh and it's not
the first time Hamas has want something
that didn't function very well he's
telling the terrorist group Hamas to
learn to shoot straight how is any of
this acceptable just look at win and
Tony blinkin staring horrified this look
in his eyes like oh this is a train
wreck by the way they all know he is a
cognitive mess at what point does
somebody stand up with Joe maybe
somebody in his family maybe is there
anybody that cares about this guy and
say Joe you're just not up to the job
anymore it's not good it's not good for
you it's not good for the country
frankly it's not good for the world let
us be clear there is no doubt
Republicans need to elect a speaker as
soon as possible they need to reopen the
people's house but we also need a
president that is far more important not
a mumbling bumbling stumbling lifeless
empty suit I mean look at that look at
that he's just tired from one little
itsy-bitsy trip no one in the media mob
will hold hold him accountable nobody on
late night television no late night
comic will even play the tape and that
writes itself their ratings would go up
50% in a week if they started playing
this so-called journalists no longer
care about truth just look at this week
dozens and dozens of major outlets in
this country ABC NBC CBS fake news CNN
msdnc the New York Times The Washington
Post Bloomberg every major Outlet the AP
they all push Hamas propaganda on the
issue of the hospital being struck by
Israel they got their talking points
from the Palestinian press themselves
they did no factchecking none whatsoever
NBC's ignorant far-left disinformation
specialist this dope named Ben Collins
rushing to blame Israel for the
explosion quickly passing off Hamas
propaganda as fact the New York Times
did the same thing publishing lies from
terrorists over and over and over again
the AP Reuters Bloomberg all these
networks that I keep telling you about
hundreds killed in Israel strike on Gaza
Hospital Palestinian officials say oh
okay that's a reliable news source and
tonight even Joe Biden clearly stated
that Israel was not behind the explosion
the IDF presented intelligence that
proved otherwise as did our own
intelligence confirm it but the damage
has been done the prop Anda has taken
hold among those that hate Israel and by
the way did anyone expect that in this
time this age this era woke political
correctness did you ever think you'd see
such virulent uh anti-Semitism in this
country on our College universities
worldwide like we're seeing now how
chilling is this and the world is now
more more chaotic more dangerous than
ever before based on the horrific events
of the past 3 years it is obvious who we
elect to that Oval Office matters you
know I'd rather have somebody that sends
out a few Mean Tweets that that foreign
adversaries the new aess of evil I call
it Iran China uh Russia probably can add
North Korea to the list you know what
they're watching and they're taking
advantage of America without a president
that is uh cognitively on their game
Biden promised to return to normaly uh
he vowed to unite the country I'd prefer
the guy that struck fear in the hearts
of President Chi and Vladimir Putin and
Kim Jong Un and the mullers in Iran I
don't think they'd be messing around
with that guy and by the way it's time
for us to restore America's standing on
the world stage the exact opposite is
happening and I did not get any more
confidence out of Joe Biden tonight
everything is worse everything's more
chaotic can ask yourself are you better
off than you were for years ago ask
yourself what policy that Joe Biden has
implemented has benefited you the
American people you know both at home
and abroad where has he been successful
and as a bonus by the way everything is
also a lot more expensive record high
inflation bad news on the mortgage front
home you know new home uh construction
has come to a screeching halt why
because 30 uh 30-year fixed rate
mortgages are now 8% that's the national
average right now under Donald Trump it
was 2.7 2.8 3 3.3 uh for a 30-year fix
rate mortgage you're now going to pay
thousands more for just just on the
interest rate that you'll pay on on your
home that you buy nobody's buying a home
and if you have a 3% 30-year fix rate
mortgage you're not going to sell it and
exchange it for an 8% 30-year fix rate
mortgage where do we go from here how do
we restore peace prosperity why is Biden
even running for a second term hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else